oh I'm so nervous oh boy thank you we'll
be in touch haha next well boy it looks
like it's my turn
wish me luck ladies My name is Matthew
Patrick and next but next excuse me but
I said next I'm the mouse you listen to
what I say Theory boy and you listen
good you'll never be a Disney princess
based on our qualifications ha ha
but what are those qualifications it's
won't little secret you don't think our
old racist movies are the only thing we
keep locked up in the Disney Vault do ya
ha ha fine you just wait Mouse time I
air your dirty little secrets
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory making enemies
with globally beloved mascots since 2015
today I look at one of the most twisted
and cutthroat cinematic universes ever
conceived the Disney Princesses old
answer one burning question that we all
never thought to ask what allows you to
qualify as a Disney Princess now that
may sound like it's a stupid question
you're a princess who happens to be in a
Disney movie duh
but the answer actually is nowhere near
that simple you see despite me going to
Disneyland hundreds of times and
constantly being the old creepy due to
waves enthusiastically to all the
princesses as they parade past what
actually got me started down this little
Vision Quest of mine was the trailer for
wreck-it Ralph - Ralph breaks the
internet which included this scene where
princess vanellope von schweetz goes to
the oh my Disney website and enters the
Disney princess room what kind of a
princess are you you have magic hair
magic hands
no do animals talk to you do people
assume all your problems got solved
because a big strong man showed up cue
the internet collectively high-fiving
each other for that sick burn on mail
Prince types got um well you got him
until you forget that princes have
literally risked their lives to save
multiple women in this room jasmine
Ariel yeah Laura you did a really good
job playing back Maleficent when she
created that mode of thorns around the
castle and then turned into a giant
dragon and started breathing green fire
everywhere oh wait no you were asleep
during that whole thing cuz Prince
Philip who did all that the same gals
it's one thing to be an empowered female
it's another thing to be an ungrateful
jerk towards the guy who saved your life
now this scene is legitimately awesome
any crossover of this caliber is always
going to be exciting it is a literal
who's who of Disney female characters
from over the decades but one thing it
is not is an accurate portrayal of
Disney Princesses you see the Disney
Princesses is a separate media franchise
created in the early 2000s it's like the
in sync of Disney animated female
characters and believe it or not it
includes only a very select portion of
the princess characters from the
Animation Studios nearly hundred year
history only eleven characters are
technically included as a Disney
Princess pause the video right now and
try to guess who those characters are
gonna be I'll give you a second or two
to pause the video all right place your
bets good some are pretty obvious Snow
White Cinderella Aurora aka Sleeping
Beauty Ariel from Little Mermaid Belle
from Beauty and the Beast and Jasmine
from Aladdin if this were a game of
Scrabble they'd be worth one point
they're like the T's and E's of the
Disney Princess world worth three points
would be Moulin Tiana from Princess and
the Frog and Rapunzel from tangled
those are the M&P tiles and the ten
pointers ease of our little game would
be Pocahontas and Madonna the first
Pixar princess coming from the movie
brave double word score now you may have
noticed some pretty big snubs from that
list like say Anna and Elsa from frozen
literal princesses from arendelle in
what is the highest-grossing animated
film of all time
no invite to this exclusive club for
either of them how about Moana also not
on the list and it's not like they're
too new either most of the modern
characters were coronated as an official
Disney Princess about a year after the
release of their movie rapunzel tiana
merida all of them had about an 11 to 12
month gap before they were officially
christened a Disney Princess and
remember this list is according to the
official list located at princess Disney
calm and official site of Disney calm
this is the real deal here so what's
going on exactly what in Disney's eyes
makes a woman worthy of being a princess
and would vanellope von schweetz
actually passed the test in merit
inclusion in this room from wreck-it
Ralph to that ladies and gentlemen is my
goal today to turn these empowered women
into lists of their core attributes so
we can directly compare their worth and
find out what methodology Disney is
working with to determine their merit so
if we have any hope of figuring out the
criteria for becoming a Disney Princess
we're gonna have to reverse engineer
things by seeing who is included
who's excluded and then figuring out
what attributes unite those two groups
now as I just mentioned the exclusion of
Anna and Elsa from this group shows that
not all princesses and Disney movies go
on to become Disney Princesses
trademarks but that leads to the
question are all Disney Princesses
trademarked actual princesses and Disney
movies in other words are they either
the daughter of a king or
or are they married to a prince well of
the eleven nine of them are easy yes but
- oh goddess and Mulan require a bit
more digging for Pocahontas her father
I hate these moments when I copy/paste a
hard name into a script and then come
across it later in the recording closet
suddenly remembering that I have to
pronounce the darn thing her father who
in the sanaka wall was a powerful chief
of the cen Kamaka was a powerful chief
of the Seneca Makkah Confederacy so
she's the daughter to a high-ranking
ruler ruler for lack of a better term
which would seem to qualify her as a
princess however there's a wrinkle here
Pocahontas his tribe didn't have Petro
lineal inheritance which means that
while Huson akka was sister's children
would be the ones next in line to
inherit any actual power not Pocahontas
that said even though she falls into
this weird middle ground of princess
dumb history seems to weigh in her favor
in 1808 james nelson barker wrote the
indian princess or labelled Sauvage one
of the first dramatizations of
Pocahontas life even earlier than that
st. George's Church yard where
Pocahontas was buried hosted the notice
of the burial of Princess Pocahontas and
later the churchyard was laid out as the
Princess Pocahontas garden in 1958 so
even though it does fall into a bit of a
middle ground consensus does seem to say
that Pocahontas can qualify as a
princess as for Milan well not so much
if you're judging her by her main movie
alone she technically doesn't qualify at
all
remember Mulan is a commoner who enlists
in the Chinese military to protect her
father sure she saves all of China from
the Huns and falls in love with Captain
Shang but nothing about that qualifies
you for the technical definition of a
princess it's not until the
direct-to-dvd sequel Mulan - where if
you squint really hard at it she becomes
a princess for like maybe five minutes
you see well what is hired to escort
three of the Emperor's daughters to be
married off to three princes
historically speaking these guys would
be better classified as warlords but
it's Disney so their princes and the
marriages will help ensure peace in
China when her love shang falls off a
cliff into a giant empty abyss no joke
this is something that really happens
Mulan assumes what any reasonable person
would assume seeing a fall like that
that he did
son so she agrees to marry one of the
princes for the good of all China so
she's almost a princess until Shang is
revealed to have lived he hears of the
marriage and rushes in at the last
minute to stop it thereby ending Milan's
entire claim to princess hood before it
even begins
so Milan no not a princess almost but
not quite so mulan really proves the
lesson here that being an actual
princess doesn't matter for
qualification into this elite group and
if you want a real nail in this coffin
who lan was included in the roster of
disney princesses back when the group
was first created in 2000 mulan too came
out in 2004 so there is absolutely zero
way that mulan would have qualified any
angle that you slice it from so being
the dictionary definition of a princess
does not matter apparently then what
does what connects those eleven
characters but still leaves out Moana
onna
Elsa not to mention other classic Disney
females like Meg from Hercules Esmerelda
from Hunchback of Notre Dom and even
princess a lone weave from 1985's the
Black Cauldron a literal princess who is
based in Welsh fairy tales and was
saving the male protagonist of her story
three decades before any of the strong
women of modern Disney rolled into town
I mean my mind immediately turned to box
office performance since those last
three movies underperformed at the
theaters but clearly that doesn't apply
to Moana and frozen heroic acts clearly
not since Moana has more heroism in her
little toe than Aurora who spends 90% of
her movie asleep
in fact it's meted out from brave who
throws a monkey wrench into a lot of the
qualifications you might expect to work
here I mean that is the entire premise
of our movie her Queen Mother attempts
to convince meted out to be a perfect
princess and Merida fights back I'm the
princess
I'm the example my life is blender
but every once in a while there's a day
when I don't have to be up first of all
like I mentioned earlier Merida was the
first Pixar princess so being part of
Disney Animation Studios to be a Disney
princess is no longer a qualifier here
which just shows you how ridiculous
these qualifications must be secondly
she was the first official Disney
Princess to not have any sort of
romantic attachment every other one of
those eleven characters have themselves
a bow sometimes hunky sometimes chunky
but there was always a man present meta
doc nope but the last difference here is
probably the biggest one Merida doesn't
sing
I mean sure there's a song about her in
the opening of the movie but Merida
herself doesn't sing a single note in
her entire film while every other Disney
Princess up to that point had so what is
it what is this magic ingredient that
I'm missing
and how does Moana miss the mark I mean
I can maybe understand on an Elsa Elsa
by the end of her movie becomes Queen
and Ana's in her shadow the whole movie
and let's face it two pale-faced
princesses from the icy north aren't the
most diverse additions to your princess
roster but mallanna literally checks off
all the boxes she's the heir apparent to
her father's chiefdom maybe not a
princess and name but certainly a
princess and function that she sings and
gets her own main theme song
[Music]
she performs heroic app she selected a
special by fate she represents a culture
and ethnicity not president the existing
11 character roster her foo he made a
butt ton of money and it came out more
than a year ago meaning that her
coronation is long past due at this
point I mean even her movie spells it
out for it's called wayfinding princess
okay first I'm not a princess I'm the
daughter of the chief same difference
you know if you wear a dress and you
have an animal sidekick your princess
wait a minute is that really it I mean
sure it's a joke but it's being told
directly to a character who has
obviously not met this invisible bar to
being a Disney princess which I gotta
admit makes the subtext for this scene
really weird but even though this meta
joke is played for laughs
Maui here might not be joking when Andi
Mooney creator of the Disney Princess
initiative was interviewed by the New
York Times about how he came up with the
idea of grouping together the princesses
he had this to say whoa standing in line
in the arena of a Disney on Ice Show I
was surrounded by little girls dressed
head-to-toe as princesses they weren't
even Disney products they were generic
princess products they depended to a
Halloween costume and the light bulb
went off clearly there was a leading
demand here so the next morning I said
to my team okay
let's establish standards and a color
palette and talk to licensees and get as
much product out there as we possibly
can that allows these girls to do what
they're doing anyway projecting
themselves into the characters from
these classic movies end quote
translation let's monetize the heck out
of the hopes and dreams of these young
impressionable girls but what if the
only two qualifications are one dress
and two animals let's look at our list
of candidates again Pocahontas dress and
Miko the raccoon and flick hummingbird
Ariel dress and floundered fish jasmine
dress and Rajah the tiger Mulan dress
and moo shu the dragon Rapunzel dress
and Pascal the chameleon Tiana dress and
Lois the crocodile Belle dress and
Philippe the horse or I guess you can
consider the Beast himself Cinderella
dress and her mice jock and gust Snow
White and Sleeping Beauty dresses and
general
woodland creatures Merida dressed and
Angus the horse and now let's look at
that excluded list meg from Hercules no
animal princess Eilonwy from Black
Cauldron no animal Esmerelda from
Hunchback okay she's got herself a
dressing a goat but she's also an outlaw
who's treated as an object of sexual
desire by the men in the movie so she's
got a couple other things working
against her in this qualification on an
Elsa sure they have Olaf but he's
technically not an animal and honestly
they do make the cut when it comes to a
separate list of Disneyland theme park
princesses in which they're the only new
additions quite frankly animal plus
dress is the only set of qualifications
that clearly delineates the princesses
from the not princesses but that still
leaves out Moana what about her she
clearly has hey hey the rooster so
what's holding her back it's the dress
display what nah we might call her
outfit first off it's technically not
addressed by dictionary definition which
is a one-piece garment for a woman or
girl that covers the body and extends
down to the legs
however Jasmine from Aladdin also
doesn't wear a traditional dress for
most of her movie so that's not the main
problem going on here what is the issue
is what Mona's dress represents consider
this according to an interview with the
site tyranny of style NASA Beauvais
visual development artist and costume
designer for Moana emphasizes the goal
of staying true to Pacific Islander
culture quote the biggest challenge on
the film was the limited materials we
only had to tapa and pan Danis table is
made from the mulberry tree bark they
pull out the bark and go through a
strenuous process of making a paste and
eventually tap it all together
hence papa similar story with the
pandanus weaving pandanus is actually a
tree and they pull the pandanus leaves
and shred them into strips these dry and
later you take each piece and weave it
together you can even braid it we had a
specific rule if you can find it in the
island you can make it end quote staying
true to the materials history and
culture of the Pacific Islands was
essential for this movie and its
characters now look at the eleven
existing princesses each and every one
wearing pretty generic attire that
alludes to their culture of origin
vaguely at best times are different now
and Disney is under more scrutiny than
ever about its appropriation of other
cultures for money it's an issue that
hung over the head of Moana from before
the movie's release and
continues to do so today with specific
focus on the costumes and if the goal of
all the Disney Princesses is to have
young girls wear your dress and look
like the character Mona's outfit while
terrifically designed and culturally
sensitive from a movie standpoint
becomes really problematic when you
start churning out cheap copies to sell
next year malls sunglass Hots so what
makes a princess well according to
Disney it's not who you are what you do
or even who you choose to marry it's
what you wear that counts and isn't that
the best message to send a little girls
next time in our exploration of Disney
Princesses we focus on that specific
scene from wreck-it Ralph to because the
roster is much wider in that room all in
an effort to determine whether vanellope
might truly become Disney's next
princess despite what all the other
girls might tell her speaking of what
you wear theorist merch is now available
for a super limited amount of time just
in the nick of time for back-to-school
you are guaranteed to get it really
quickly after you order it admittedly
this round emerge has mainly focused
around game theory but don't worry next
time there will be film theory stuff
specifically but if you want yourself an
amazing heavy-duty backpack and awesome
shirt that might not make you feel like
a princess but will make you feel like a
million bucks what has become my
favorite pair of socks because of how
soft they are a theorist pops socket for
your phone so you don't drop it on your
face while you're watching Disney movies
lying in bed at night or a theorist
notebook of your very own that might
contain a mystery for you to unravel
click the link in the description below
hey you can tell a disney princess by
what they wear why not be able to tell
the theorists by what they wear as well
looking stylish and bright glaring neon
green I'd like to see it Disney Princess
pull that one off click the link in the
description to check out that virtue
which every purchase comes with little
bonus gifts filled in there too which is
pretty cool guys make sure you curtsy in
the direction of that subscribe button
so you don't miss next week's episode
where we take an analysis of vanellope
von schweetz and time from wreck-it
Ralph to I'm excited about that one
anytime you get to expose blatant
corporate greed it's usually pretty
an episode that I'm always very excited
to do so anyway check it out click the
subscribe button and most importantly lo
remember that's just a theory of film
theory and cuts